à ce soir donc vous nous disait vous
avez été choqué oui par des mots
extrêmement crue grossier vulgaire
diffusé dans burger quiz hier soir
franchement ils ont la carte donc ya pas
de levée de boucliers mais moi je
voulais qu'on en parle parce que j'ai
trouvé ça inadmissible on peut écouter
si vous voulez regarder moi il faut
vraiment se calmer les images la réponse
contient le son beat goes around orbite
si vous ne savez pas dit [ __ ] là plutôt
cela beat juste au dessus des couilles
j'habite deux mois que c'est la [ __ ]
barritt fiction que ça peut aussi servir
pour la [ __ ] entre les poils et des
couilles et habite un plat 3 ça fait
très bien franchement ça frédéric c'est
pas sympa c'est vous non vous êtes vous
avez pris vous avez pris 20 ans n'en
nourrit non ça dans votre tête mais
beaucoup de gens sont choqués par cédric
tille et d'ailleurs les audiences
s'effondra mois tout le matin vie ça que
les audiences s'effondraient confiant
mais c'est pas pour ça n'allait pas
merci en tout cas où la vie